und in unseren köpfen sind noch so sehr
die bilder von der jahrhundertflut aus
dem vergangenen sommer jetzt wieder
hochwasseralarm in deutschland
vielerorts tretende flüsse und bäche
über die ufer gehwege und straßen sind
überflutet und gesperrt betroffen ist
unter anderem die franken region in
bayern darunter die städte coburg
bamberg und ansbach aber auch rheinland
pfalz dort treten die flüsse wie die
mode zum beispiel über die ufer
überflutungen gibt es auch im kreis
bernkastel-wittlich nahe der stadt trier
sowie in koblenz und das sind bilder die
uns erinnern ja 40 autominuten davon
entfernt sorgen diese worte
hochwasserflut natürlich für
erinnerungen genau wie bei uns an eine
katastrophe die sich so tief in uns aber
vor allen dingen deren köpfe dort
eingebrannt hat die rede ist natürlich
vom anteil der region in der die
jahrhundertflut den menschen wirklich
alles genommen hat das war im juli
vergangenen jahres die tödlichen
wassermassen die haben dass schäden
angerichtet in höhe von milliarden euro
134 menschen sind allein dort gestorben
im aartal tausende menschen haben ihre
existenz verloren ihr gesamtes hab und
gut bis heute laufen ja die
aufräumarbeiten und die werden noch viel
viel länger leider laufen dort in dieser
region die angst sind der von der flut
weiterhin gebeutelten region geht um das
ist klar die angst ist es wieder zu
einer solch bedrohlichen lage kommen
könnte wir wollen jetzt in das halten um
zu erfahren wie die menschen mit den
hochwasser meldungen umgehend vor ort
ist unser kollege til biermann
derzeit die situation im aartal
ja wir sind hier im recht das ist ein
ort der auch besonders betroffen war
hinter mir sieht man die brücke die auch
halb abgebrochen ist denn das war eine
brücke an der sich die bäume und der
unrat so gesammelt hatten das wirklich
eine sieben meter flutwelle über das tal
geschwemmt war hinter mir sind auch
immer noch häuser die halb abgebrochen
sind und als die menschen jetzt hier
vorgestern warnungen bekam vom landkreis
dass der der pegel wieder ansteigt haben
sie auch wirklich angst bekommen dass
ich so etwas wiederholen könnte
die stets darum warnungen das war ja ein
riesen thema in der flugkatastrophe man
ist nicht rechtzeitig gewarnt worden wie
läuft das jetzt aktuell wenn wir von
steigenden pegeln wiederhören man wird
maximal wachsam sein aber funktionieren
die systeme dort
ich habe mit einem chef der freiwilligen
feuerwehr von der now gesprochen und der
sagte es sind jetzt keine großartigen
neuen systeme installiert worden aber
man ist jetzt hier natürlich sehr
ängstlich dann vorgestern ist der pegel
etwas gestiegen der normalerweise bei 80
cm der war am ende dann bei 1 meter 80
und dann haben gleich alle etwas angst
bekommen und es gibt dann solche apps es
gibt zum beispiel die app main pegel da
können die bewohner hier
aktuell immer checken wie gerade der
pegelstand an der ahr ist außerdem gibt
es eine app die heißt cut war und auch
der landkreis ist jetzt wirklich sind
super geworden und sobald irgendwie
etwas sich andeutet berichten sie dass
auch auf facebook und versuchen die
bevölkerung dazu waren selbe mann für
uns immer teil vielen herzlichen dank
für deine einschätzungen und wir bitten
sie liebe zuschauern zuschauer zu
entschuldigen dass das bild so manchmal
geflackert hat das liegt eben an der
verbindung ins abteil die dort auch noch
nicht so richtig steht und wir habe
gerade mit till über diese warnsysteme
gesprochen über die ängste natürlich
dort in der katastrophenregion und
unsere frage ist jetzt funktioniert das
besser hat die politik hat die
verwaltung gelernt aus dieser
flutkatastrophe im vergangenen sommer
funktionieren die warnsysteme diese
frage haben wir gestellt nordrhein
westfalens innenminister herbert reul
okay der liegt im moment noch nicht vor
höre ich gerade reichen wir gleich nach
wir wollen aber dann weiter über die
ernsthaftigkeit dieser lage sprechen
also wie groß ist die gefahr dass es zu
neuen schweren hochwassern dort kommen
könnte ja und darüber sprechen wir
gleich mit karsten brandt jetzt schauen
wir aber einmal noch rein herbert reul
was sagt ihr dazu gibt es denn jetzt die
warnung in metallischen allerdings
angekündigt dass
wir verblüffend schnell vorangekommen
sind da zuständig ist ja der bund wir
haben als noch trabis fälschen ist wie
immer dafür geworben dieses l
broadcasting zu bekommen wir haben jetzt
die zwei rechtlichen grundlagen im
bundesrat und ob beim
telekommunikationsgesetz geändert das
ist im november und dezember geschieden
worden es würden die technischen
voraussetzungen jetzt bis mitte januar
gibt es eine verordnung die da
vorbereitet wird da gibt es zeit punkte
zu stellungnahmen und ich gehe davon aus
hoffe dass wir in diesem jahr das dann
da mal anwenden können aber das dauert
alles ein wenig obwohl es finde ich fast
7 beratungen an geht zügig funktioniert
hat die fachleute in berlin also die
zuständigen stellen sagen dass es im
jahre 22 wirksam werden soll
ja noch ist also das problem nicht
abgestellt auch wenn er politik dran ist
das versichert also nordrhein westfalens
innenminister herbert reul aber problem
nach wie vor nicht gelöst wir wollen mit
unserem meteorologen mit karsten brandt
darüber sprechen wie groß die gefahr
aktuell vor allen dingen teil ist also
ob jemand hat uns gerade geschildert
natürlich schaut man mit sorge auf die
pegelstände dort zurecht oder können sie
ein stück entwarnung geben der brand
also grüßen nach berlin ich kann
entwarnung geben ganz klar ich bin
gerade zufällig zu welcher weise in der
eifel und auch oberhalb des art hals und
wir beobachten natürlich gerade auch bei
so einer wetterlage hier immer die die
niederschlagsmengen das ist hier was wir
jetzt an situationen haben eine
klassische winter kleine winter
hochwasserwelle die nicht wirklich
dramatisch gefährlich ist also ich kann
ganz klar entwarnen nicht nur fürs
theater sondern auch zum beispiel für
die mosel und auch für das rheintal da
werden die höchsten pegelstände in der
mosel liegen die schon hinter uns im
rheintal fließt die welle gerade ohne
schäden zwischen bonn und düsseldorf ab
also wir werden da heute die höchsten
pegel marken erreichen und werden dann
dort diese hochwasserwelle richtung
nordsee laufen sie ähnlich ist es dann
auch an donau und main auch dort haben
wir ja morgen keiner hochwasserwarnungen
auch dort wird das heute noch lokalen
einflüssen zu steigenden pegeln kommen
aber zumeist ist das schlimmste da auch
schon durch auch dort war das in
anführungsstrichen er das übliche
winterhochwasser also ein wirklicher
stresstest das sage ich auch mal ganz
deutlich war das jetzt noch nicht das
muss man hier jedes jahr mehr oder
weniger erwartet das kann auch gut sein
dass wir in den nächsten wochen noch mal
an der ahr aber auch an donau ein
ähnliches hochwasser wieder erleben
werden also nichts dramatisches aber wir
haben natürlich immer ein auge drauf
ganz kann wie schaut es aus mit blick
auf's wochenende retten dort die
bundesländer zu erwarten die jetzt mit
dem wasser zu kämpfen haben also der
entspannung der hochwasserlage ganz klar
aber eine vorwarnung und ich glaube das
ist ganz wichtig für alle die mit dem
auto unterwegs sind wir werden am
samstag und am sonntag probleme auf den
straßen sehen ein erstes schnee
sturmtief kommt herein am samstag
betrifft besonders nrw
rheinland-pfalz und baden-württemberg
gerade in nrw ist man ja den schnee
nicht so gewohnt mildeste mildeste gegen
deutschlands plus temperaturen
samstagmorgen kann es sein dass dann der
schnee runter kommt bis in die städte
hinein also dass selbst köln düsseldorf
oder das ruhrgebiet kurzzeitig mal weiß
werden aber wenn man dann auf den
autobahnen unterwegs ist nach einem fall
vielleicht auch nach baden württemberg
ist es ja auch noch ein bisschen
reiserückkehrer da würde ich wirklich
vorwarnen den samstagmorgen zu nehmen
weil dieses kleine steht tief hat es in
sich sobald man ein bisschen höher kommt
zwar drei meter durch den westerwald
darin baden württemberg vielleicht
irgendwo unterwegs ist dann über die
schwäbische alb dann hat man mehrere
zentimeter neuschnee erhebliche
verkehrsprobleme am samstag
sonntag die vorwarnung für nord- und
ostdeutschland dass ein zweiter
schneetief was dann reinkommt wird dort
dann für probleme sorgen also am
wochenende nicht das hochwasser unser
problem sondern schnee und glätte auf
den straßen bitte vorbereitet sein danke
herzlich an den meteorologe karsten
brandt dritte also entwarnung gibt für
das aartal in sachen hochwasser der aber
schneealarm ausruft sozusagen für das
wochenende und vielleicht allen
langläufern in der innenstadt von köln
ein bisschen hoffnung macht